[Music]
not since the spanish flu 100 years ago
has a pandemic caused such devastation
in the world
but this time around there's a
fundamental difference
data we'll be putting up charts behind
me so the first slide
shows the number of people coming
forward and testing positive for covid
next slide please it's been used to
better understand
track and prevent the spread of covet
19.
the global pandemic coverage has
propelled data into the mainstream
at the economist the analysis and
presentation of these data
has defined our coverage it's also
informed
and influenced policymakers this chart
went viral
suddenly it was absolutely everywhere
even a week later you would start to see
that in government briefings
in a conversation with economist
subscribers our data journalists
provided an inside story
into some of their standout work are
there any particular
um examples you would point to that you
that you like or that you're
particularly proud of
yeah there's a piece uh james french and
one of our data journalists
wrote um almost exactly a year ago
where this was before i think any
country really had locked down
um and we we wanted to find out how
different cities different countries
were reacting to
to the virus so he he looked at google
maps and he noticed in the bottom
left-hand corner there's a little um
i think it's called a sort of busyness
indicator it tells you how many people
are in a certain place at a certain time
and he had an
amazing idea he thought if he could
scrape that for lots of key
places in lots of cities he could get a
real-time idea of
how many people were actually out and
about in in rome which was
you know one of the uh italy was one of
the countries here early on um
in london in new york and paris so he
set up a
script that would scrape um that little
bar chart
in the corner several times a day
for um i think 18 or 20
locations in 13 cities around the world
for a week
and at the end of it you have 150 000 uh
json files if you
work with them you know that they can
take a bit of parsing
but he was able to turn that into a
really interesting and informative
piece on which cities were locking down
and
which were still going about their
business so
you know this showed you know almost a
critical week um
in march 2020 that rome was
really starting to sort of lock down um
new york hadn't really changed london
hadn't even really started to
to lock down when your team finds data
like that and builds your child
does it um influence your other
journalism i can imagine
that stories sometimes or written
stories also sometimes emerge
from the data department rather than the
other way around it
with that example is that what happens
um i think with that one
james thought there would be something
there and he um
he's great today to analyze it and he
was right but he also
um i think when people saw that
they thought well actually this is a
really interesting data set
um and i think soon after google made
that data available to everyone
and now and you know even a week later
you would start to see that in
government briefings
this kind of mobility um google mobility
as a measure of
country's response to coronavirus
so it really took off from there how
much do your
do your team indeed scrape those kind of
openly available sources versus
versus other types of um of data
quite a lot really it's um because
the anything you scrape hasn't generally
been scraped before it's not available
so nobody really knows what stories are
in that data
set so you have to do it yourself really
james showed me
his um his code for scraping it it was
40 lines long it was a tiny bit of code
yet it provided
such a rich and interesting data set
that it's not
um it's not a massive ordeal to do to do
this
now all of us obviously work above all
else to
please our subscribers and feed them
interesting pieces of information but
occasionally
the reach goes beyond that this is the
flatten
the curve um diagram or chart actually
um which i'm not just making this up
which has had a real
impact beyond just entertaining people
can you tell us
what we're looking at and
yeah how and why did you design this
chart
um yes so uh back in march
which feels like an eons ago and our
healthcare correspondent suggested that
we
make our own version of this cdc chart
which you can see
on the far left here um i thought it was
a
really brilliant and simple illustration
of an important concept namely what the
intended impact of social distancing
measures is so
firstly to delay the epidemic and
secondly to reduce the height of the
epidemic peak
um so the middle one here is the one
that i designed from this chart on the
left
as you can see i kept quite close to the
original design
just because for the sake of accuracy
my main changes were just getting rid of
the y-axis because because it's a
diagram i decided i didn't actually
really need it
and i also labelled the curves directly
to remove an extra step of
interpretation
and then around a week after this an
academic called drew harris
made his own version of the diagram and
crucially
he added a line for healthcare system
capacity
and so this is a small addition but
really really important
and it really caught everyone's
imagination this chart went viral
suddenly it was absolutely everywhere
from tv
uh news to um
i think the uk government had it in one
of their briefings
so yeah that was really great um i think
it really opened people's
uh mines to data visualization as a tool
for communication
particularly during a pandemic suddenly
i saw loads of news articles sort of
leading with data views in a way that
maybe they hadn't before
i'm slashing out a public policy editor
at the economist thanks for watching
please visit the link to the left to see
a schedule of our upcoming events
subscribers can also see previous
sessions there thanks again for watching
and don't forget to subscribe to our
youtube channel
you